Archie and Louie are around the same
ages so what does that relationship like
is there a relationship between the two
cousins between Archie and Louis well I
don't think there is much of a
relationship between the Royals cousins
I mean there's an ocean between them an
actual physical ocean and then there's
an ocean between the brothers and so
actually you know what Harry had always
hoped for for this closeness with royal
cousins which is what he has with Zara
Phillips and and Peter Phillips and all
of his Royal cousins it's just never had
the opportunity and um you know there
hasn't really been a moment for the
Royal cousins to properly come together
that's so sad I hate that this Royal
Rift has just been this fascinating
topic for so many people and you write
in your book that you say that William
hasn't been able to forgive Harry
stepping back for numerous reasons so
now that William is taking on these
additional roles and responsibilities
now that Charles is king of in in head
of the monarchy how will the Brotherhood
evolve from here moving forward now that
they are giving these new positions will
we see any sort of repairs in this Rift
between the Brotherhood well I think
everyone
want hair in the Riff because it doesn't
do anyone any good to have this rift at
the heart of the House of Windsor you
know I know that as much as as the King
has got big issues and they are big
issues the Commonwealth keeping the
kingdom United I mean that's what keeps
him up at night but he also has this
familial Rift that is overshadowing the
start of his ring because it is
generating headlines it is generating
talking points and it is certainly
something that he's going to need to
sort out I mean I in the process of
writing this book I really wanted to get
to the bottom as to whether there could
be a Reconciliation and I spoke to AIDS
past and present including one very
senior aide who'd worked with the
brothers for a good 10 years who knows
them both and still speaks to them both
and actually he was surprisingly
confident that there can be our
reproachment but it is going to be some
time down the line and that is largely
down to the fact that William simply
cannot forgive Harry not just for
leaving but for how he left
foreign